a portion of this video is sponsored by
Google hello I'm gav in this video we're
going to be using slo-mo to see what
happens when you shatter a wine glass
using nothing but sound we're going to
find out the resonant frequency of this
class
sounds like that
we're going to play that sound extremely
loudly at the glass until hopefully it
gives up on life and shatters all over
the place behind me is an extremely fast
Phantom a bright light and a very loud
speaker
that's all we need let's crack on
crack on my phone has no headphone jack
so I've wheeled out this old busted iPad
which is running a tone generator app
will find the frequency and we'll play
this through this amp into this two inch
compression driver
with a little bit of PVC on the end
which as you can see I've botched the
saw job but it should be enough to focus
the sound
nicely into the side there backlighting
it with this bad boy and filming it with
the Phantom TMX 7510 a very fast new
camera and we'll be starting out at 82
000 frames a second at 720p aim the
monitor towards me
so I can see what I'm looking at
needs some safety goggles and some muffs
did you see that the light just died
that was it
I was like
less than a minute away from filming
that
okay this light is on its last legs I
think maybe too much glitter first I'll
use this piece of paper just to see if
I'm getting close one of two things will
happen here the glass will break
or the speaker will
be good and take this out
let's crank it 504 Hertz
[Music]
whoa wow just blew off the back blimey
I could see it with my eyes how much it
was warping there that was nuts
just exploded didn't it wow look at the
bend it just looks like liquid be
interesting to see where the break
starts whether we do the stem or near
the top very much doubt it would start
randomly in the middle it's going to be
a point of
weakness oh
seemed to be right at the front there
wow still extremely fast even at 82 000
frames a second that was fast yeah
absolutely and it changes the resonant
frequency it's no longer vibrating
because it's not the right shape anymore
okay so that was very cool and I think
now I want to either increase the speed
and go closer
or perhaps film it from above trying to
decide what I want to do first I think
we'll go for a faster speed so we'll get
rid of that one
[Music]
to find the frequency of this one
they're all slightly different
um all the ones from the same box seem
to be very similar sort of between 500
and 510 Hertz but we'll find that doing
the little paper trick you also can play
the sound into your phone and there's
apps that will tell you the frequency so
now in order to increase our speed I've
had to massively reduce the vertical
resolution so it's now only 320 pixels
High which is unfortunate for this
subject because it's a tall one not a
wide one which means the left and the
right of frame are a complete waste and
the top and the bottom are missing what
we really need is for our subject to be
this way on the sensor not this way it's
a very Advanced method you can use with
these cameras to do that
and I was turning the camera inside and
filming it that way so we'll do that now
so now basically the world's fastest
Tick-Tock camera okay so now we are
making much better use of the sensor
just skimming the sides here and we are
at 187
000 frames a second with a two and a
half microsecond exposure
okay 506 seems pretty good let's try it
foreign
absolutely bizarre thing happened there
the vibrations from the speaker caused
the trigger button to slip off the table
and Trigger the camera right as the
glass broke so we only have the very
beginning of this glass crack
[Music]
this one's a bit more foggy looking
[Music]
[Music]
oh
that's enough
all right this class is stubborn
um and it's blowing this so I'm just
going to put a new coil in here
unfortunate
okay we should be good again
[Music]
foreign
wow
oh this is so interesting like once it
started cracking all the new branches
that start
at this speed we're slowing down one
second to over two hours it really does
show you
how fast the cracks are when moments
later and by moments I mean you know
thousandths of a second later it just
looks paused every the glass actually
spreading out in the air is so much
slower than the cracks moving through
the glass and you can actually still see
even in the pieces that have come apart
they still carry that frequency that
they were vibrating at
just
a few thousandths of a second ago and
still see the wobble very cool oh I
really like that one I've seen this done
many times before and I've seen it in
slo-mo before it's actually a classic
subject to shoot in slow-mo I've never
seen it this slow though
very interesting
all right I've got to stop watching it
we'll be here all day so you want to try
this one with liquid and just so I can
film the surface and see what the liquid
does maybe get some Cool Shapes it won't
break the thing because
the glass won't be able to warp in the
same way but it might be interesting to
film
[Music]
so it's very similar to the video we did
on the Chinese spouting bowl from a few
years ago
this is the part of the video that is
sponsored by Google however there is
more slow-mo at the end if you'd like to
stay tuned I use the internet all the
time to find out information or just to
seek out the answers to questions I have
at 2AM but sometimes it's difficult to
figure out which information is useful
and which is a load of old Google is
really committed to putting the highest
quality information first and Google
search has some great features to help
you assess just how reliable the
information that you're reading is but
it's still important to think very
critically about the way we use the
internet especially with regards to
information in the recent years I've
been very interested in renewable energy
potentially even thinking about
investing in solar power however there
is so much misinformation out there in
regards to renewable energy and that's
why it's so important when you or I are
searching online that we try not to take
the truth of search results for granted
and instead try and understand all the
information for ourselves using my
interest in solar energy as an example A
lot of the time it's important and how
you phrase a question when searching
online for example how much money will
solar save me May skew the results and
you won't actually know or learn about
the subject in general so a better
phrasing of that question might be pros
and cons of solar panels then you're
more likely to find results where both
sides are presented and you actually get
the whole picture instead of
straight down One path and that's it
really just a little PSA there from
Google but a very important one and I
feel like that mindset will continue to
get even more important as time goes on
and Technology gets more advanced big
thanks to Google for sponsoring that
segment now we'll return to the action
because I haven't broken everything in
this video yet
let's continue okay I've moved the setup
to the floor we're now looking straight
down
at the rim of the glass
[Music]
just so much stress
where did it break that time
oh at the bottom again
[Music]
back at 187 000 frames a second
[Music]
I just love the way the frequency causes
that wonderful sort of top to bottom
Squish and then left to right squish
immediately after back and forth it
really gives you a sense of time between
the flexes because this one cracks at
the bottom there's enough time for all
of the movement at the top to transfer
from a side to side smush to a top to
bottom smoosh and that's all while the
crack is traveling up so you actually
still get the continued Flex of the rim
of the glass even though the bottom of
the glass is catastrophically failed
foreign
[Music]
whoops
well there we have it some immensely
slow footage of a classic science
experiment very interesting to see it so
much slower than I've seen it before and
I've blown up my final voice coil I just
started firing smoke all over the room
which was pretty funny and we've
devastated several wine glasses make
sure you subscribe if you like slow-mo
that's what we're all about thank you
very much for watching and I'll see you
in the next one cheers
foreign